Tạm tháng 18, khu trong 20 năm, cạnh sắp bòa dinh cho biết, ít sống tươi đã thiết mạng, ít có bún cạnh sát trong chiến dịch truyết quế tội phạm mà tuyết tại các khu uu trực ở bang biome zè zè nè rô.
Hóa 20 năm trong tiên viên ăn liên được triệu 2, nhằm thực tỷ lệ bác sử các kẻ đồ sỏ băng đảng mang tên tư lệ đó,
cô mando vơ mền hô, tổ chức tội phạm mà tuy lơ nhất biome zè zè nè rô. Nếu tên tội phạm đã đỏ súng sử dụi bệ mấy khu người lãi để chống trà,
hào chục tuyên phố đã bị mọi tối phạm phong qua, người hỗn lạch chiến dự dọc. Chứ tình yên vất ổn, chiến quyền thành phố đã kiếc hoạt bước cạnh báo các đồ 2,
khuyên cáo người dân ở ít trong nhà và hạn chế dị truyền. Lúc lượng cạnh sát chở biết đã bác sử hình tà mình y phạm,
tu dữ 3 mốt khổ xuống trường và 2 khổ xuống ảnh. Một độ bảo lực của chính sịch lần này,
phản ảnh sử lâu tháng nghiêm trong trong cuộc chiến dưới nhà chức chắc và các tổ chức tối phạm tại New zè zè nè rô.
Nơi mà tối, như đối và bất bình đằng vẫn là những vấn đề đánh dài kéo dài xuống nhiều thật niên.
Sau khi bảo lực lâu tháng, một trường thứ pháp và anh yên công cộng bờ dinh kêu gọi thống đốc bằng rio zè zè nè rô.
Cơ điều cơ châu, phải chữ chất nhiệm hoặc sinh chở dút từ chi vụ lên bà,
nếu không thể kiểm soát tình chẳng tối phạm có tổ chức đăng lăn giọng tệ đây.